of course happy to take your questions
um so as the president remains focused
on lowering costs for american families
we have a number of announcements today
that will help households save money on
utility bills first the department of
energy announced over 3 billion from
president biden's bipartisan
infrastructure law is now available
through the weatherization assistance
program for states and territories to
retrofit households make homes more
energy efficient and save families money
the president's infrastructure law
increased this program's resources
tenfold which means more homeowners will
be able to improve insulation upgrade
lighting and appliances and electrify
heating and cooling systems all of which
save families hundreds of dollars per
year while making homes more resilient
to climate change and extreme
temperatures second the department of
energy is proposing new energy saving
standards for household appliances and
equipment as part of a roadmap to
complete 100 actions this year that
would save families more than 100
annually on their utility bills and
that's actually a very conservative
estimate 100 annually on their utility
bills
to give one example of the impacts u.s
households buy over 7 million room air
conditioners every year and today we're
proposing a new efficiency standard that
would save consumers up to 275 dollars
over the life of the product
energy also announced new codes that
will make federal buildings more energy
efficient reduce operating costs and
ensure we are good stewards of taxpayer
dollars
together these efforts can save more
than 15 billion in net costs reduce
greenhouse gas emissions and advance
environmental justice
from implementing his infrastructure law
to updating important standards these
actions show the president following
through on his mission to lower costs
for working families and help them save
money each month on their energy bills
and then secondly i'd like to say
yesterday the full senate took its first
vote on the nomination of lisa cook an
important step forward toward confirming
her and our other qualified nominees for
the federal reserve we need to confirm
dr cook along with the other three
qualified nominees jerome powell for
chair lael brainerd for vice chair and
philip jefferson for a seat on the board
of governors so that the federal reserve
can move ahead in its work to help
address inflation we call on senators on
both sides of the aisle to support these
nominees because they are imminently
qualified to serve this is important and
we hope the senate can get it done soon
so they can get to work
so thank you very much and with that
ap thanks kate um
ap reporting uh plans by the
administration
to uh end title 42 by may 23rd
is the byte administration prepared to
deal with the aftermath of ending title
42
and the expected influx of migrants
so first what i would say is that this
is a decision that we have long deferred
to cdc title 42 is a public health
directive it is not an immigration or
migration enforcement measure so the
decision on when to lift title 42 we
defer to the cdc um
that being said of course we are
planning for
multiple contingencies and we have every
expectation that when the cdc ultimately
decides it's appropriate to lift title
42 there will be an influx of people to
the border and so we are doing a lot of
work to plan for that contingency i
think you saw yesterday the department
of homeland security
did a briefing walking through some of
the planning that they're doing to
increase efficiency to ensure that we
have the capacity to ensure that
we are
operating in a way that's that is
treating migrants humanely fairly uh so
you heard from them yesterday on some of
the planning that they're doing more
broadly now not specifically tied to
title 42 or or an ultimate decision to
lift it but just more broadly to the
work that they're doing to uh to
continue to build up our migration
system and ensure that we are restoring
order at the border and and then
secondly um
if putin has bad information
i've heard you classified u.s
intelligence
what does that mean for the war in
ukraine in the prospects for
negotiations right now well i certainly
am not a spokesperson for the kremlin
and cannot speak to what is in vladimir
putin's head
what i can say
is of course we have information that
putin felt misled by the russian
military which has resulted in
persistent tension between putin and his
military leadership we believe that
putin is being misinformed by his
advisors about how badly the russian
military is performing and how the
russian economy is being crippled by
sanctions because his senior advisers
are too afraid to tell him the truth
so
it is increasingly clear uh that putin's
war has been a strategic blunder that
has left russia weaker over the long
term and increasingly isolated on the
world stage
on that i mean in the lead-up to
russia's invasion of ukraine the
administration declassified information
like this to sort of lay out what
putin's intentions were you seem to be
doing that again now uh by making it
clear that he's being misled by his
advisors he just decides what's the hope
and the goal in going public with this
now
so again i think what this does is paint
a picture of what a strategic error
putin and and russia have made here we
saw from the outset that they for
example made a aggressive push toward
kiev at the beginning of of the invasion
uh they are now publicly trying to
redefine the goals of their uh invasion
to be um to be different than they were
at the outset i think
uh putting forward this information uh
simply contributes to uh a sense that
this has been a strategic error for them
again i'm not going to characterize you
know what they are thinking i'm
certainly not going to characterize uh
how they may or may not use this
information to make decisions that's not
my place but i do think that making this
information public
contributes to an understanding that
this has been a strategic failure for
russia obviously we will continue to
pursue our strategy of imposing severe
costs on russia and trying to strengthen
ukraine on the battlefield and at the
negotiating table
being misinformed like this then who is
really pulling the strings here
that's not a question that i'm able to
speak to from this podium i think this
is a again i don't speak for the kremlin
uh what i can speak to is what the
information that we see uh which again
as i say shows that he has felt misled
by the russian military and has resulted
in this persistent tension
how does this impact concerns about
whether you know any deal that may be
negotiated with russia between russia
and ukraine can be trusted
well again we are not negotiators in
that process we are obviously in close
contact with ukrainians as they work
through this process again our role is
to do everything we can to strengthen
ukraine on the battlefield as we've done
with the security assistance the
unprecedented amount of security
assistance and weapons that we've flowed
to to ukraine and also to strengthen
strengthen their hands at the
negotiating table by continuing to apply
uh incredibly severe costs and sanctions
uh on russia
intelligence um is your is your
expectation that releasing this
information um
is are you hoping that it changes
putin's calculus or the military's
calculus as they approach these things
uh it is that is not our intent our
intent is simply to make the information
available uh so that there is a full
understanding
of what kind of strategic blunder this
has been uh for russia and for the
russian people and is there anything and
more that you can share just about um
you know
whether this is an assessment that
you're extremely confident in i know you
know
typically there's a range of views among
analysts across the intelligence
agencies about how solid information is
is there anything you can tell us about
how solid this is and
what is underlying this that gives you
the confidence that this is the right
reading well i can't speak uh more
specifically to the intelligence
because we obviously do not do anything
to compromise sources or methods i will
simply say we have made it public and
allow you to draw a conclusion from that
so does the u.s believe that putin is
now fully aware of the misinformation
that he now has a clear picture of
russia's uh military operations and how
badly it is performing
well again i would just say that we
obviously have information which we have
now made public that he felt misled by
the russian military
we believe he's being misinformed by his
advisers about how badly the russian
military is performing and how the
russian economy is being crippled by
sanctions because again his senior
advisors are too afraid to tell him the
truth uh beyond that i can't
characterize i can't characterize any
further than that are there any um
examples that you might be able to offer
us other than putin not knowing
initially that uh his military was using
and losing conscripts in ukraine
that
show how putin was potentially being
misinformed by his advisors i don't have
any detail beyond what we've made public
already
one more um u.s officials have obviously
been saying since yesterday that the us
is not going to be fooled by
russian claims about a withdrawal from
ukraine
uh until you all see it happen on the
ground does president zielenski share in
that skepticism
i'm sorry i apologize ask that one more
time
you all have been saying that you're not
going to be fooled by
russia's assessment or promises that it
is going to start withdrawing uh and
start pulling back on military attacks
in ukraine wondering if president
zielenski since he spoke with president
biden does he share that assessment well
i won't i won't characterize president
zielinski's thinking but i will say that
we continue to see evidence today of
russia
attacking advancing attacking in places
where they had previously said they
would not so i think um that is uh
self-evident and obviously we continue
uh to do everything we can to flow
assistance security assistance uh to the
uh to the
hey ukrainians um back to title 42 for a
minute um back in the spring of last
year there was a very large surge of
family's record surge of children at the
migrant children at the border
that overwhelmed
border patrol stations took a long time
to get them moved into hhs into sort of
temporary shelters and then ultimately
to hhs
since then there hasn't been a major
overhaul of the immigration system
legislation that the president proposed
is completely stalled in congress um
you know there have been some sort of
tweaks and and
and
changes around the edges but there
hasn't been a wholesale kind of
rethinking or change of the asylum
system at the border uh the mpp
program that donald trump put into place
is is back in place by a court order but
it's also at a very low level so what is
there
in place now if there is another surge
in the next month or two when this is
lifted what is there in place that gives
the administration confidence that
that
some different result will happen than
happened a year ago
well i think if you look back to the
spring to the time period you're
referencing um
there was an effort to move those
unaccompanied minors as quickly as
possible out of border patrol custody
and into facilities that were more
suited for children and we were able to
dramatically reduce those numbers they
were in the thousands uh over the course
of a couple of months uh through the
work of dhs and others
and hhs i should say
we were able to dramatically reduce
those numbers move those kids quickly
out of border patrol
border patrol custody and into uh into
the system so i think um you know if you
look at what we were able to do last
spring there was uh there was an ability
to uh to move those numbers and move
those children uh uh quickly into uh
more
into facilities that were uh better
suited for them
writ large i would uh again point to the
things that the president has done to
try to rebuild what was if you remember
when we came into office a system that
was decimated by the previous
administration the previous
administration spent four years trying
to tear apart uh a lot of the uh pieces
of our uh immigration system uh and so
we were in many ways building from you
know i won't say scratch certainly but
we were building from uh a place where
a lot of these pieces have been torn
down so
what we focused on and what the
president has focused on uh is working
with the department of homeland security
to give clear guidance for internal
enforcement
and
newly designating tps temporary
protected status for a number of
countries restarting the central
american miners program that the
previous administration ended
putting together the family
reunification task force which we have
made some progress on reunifying some of
those families who were torn apart under
the previous administration um of course
ending the muslim ban and the public
charge rule and protecting daca
recipients so
this president has taken uh numerous
important substantive steps of course
there is more work to do there is
absolutely more work to do but we've
taken
serious strides forward since we took
office last year
one quick follow-up um
you
said again the line that the
administration has used a lot which is
that the title 42 isn't an immigration
uh policy it's a public health policy
has the president as ron klain has
anybody else in the senior
administration tried to overrule
the cdc over during the past year
in its efforts to lift title ii prior to
now no
okay
thank you um on kovid um
can you
help us understand
you guys have laid out or what happens
if the money runs out
that you're requesting you remind us
what in the view of the white house is
the most urgent item on that list that
runs the risk of not being funded and
republicans again today are saying the
money for this is there in previously
passed legislation there's one figure
they're saying is 160 billion dollars
is there from the coca relief bill
what is the white house response to that
suggestion
uh so firstly uh this is funding that's
going to be used to uh to provide tests
it will uh fund additional vaccines for
example as we were talking about
yesterday should there become a time
where
a fourth shot is recommended for the
broader population
it will
it will also fund life-saving treatments
and also our ability to uh to
additionally provide vaccines around the
world which is another piece of ensuring
that the virus is not able
to
to move around the globe
so you know this is critically important
funding the stakes are very real and
very high
you have heard the president state this
repeatedly that this is critical in
order for us to continue our progress
the other thing i would say about this
funding is that it will allow us to
prepare for the eventuality the
possibility i shouldn't say eventuality
the possibility um of another variant
another wave it will give us the funding
that we need to be prepared for the
future so um it is critically urgent in
that way and i'm sorry what was the
second question they say the money's
already there that there's unused funds
from previously passed legislation
so obviously we initially proposed this
as emergency uh funding but we are uh
working with the congress the congress
is working to get this done the
president's been very clear that it
should get done how the uh how the
mechanism of finally coming to an
agreement on this uh works out we'll
leave that to the congress but uh the
president's been very clear that we need
this funding and that it's urgent
something he said earlier that he may
have a meeting
with the family of trevor reed they're
trying to make that happen is that
happening today or something soon don't
yet know if it's happening today but i
spoke to the president about this
earlier you obviously all heard from him
he is uh very eager to meet with the
family and we're working through when
that's possible
thank you kate um i want to ask you
about the call with president zielinski
but just a couple more um on this new
information about putin being left in
the dark by his military advisors who
authorized the release of that
intelligence
that's not something i can speak to
obviously
it was declassified and put forward into
the public sphere can you say did the
president sign off on this i cannot
speak to that except to say that this is
information that we declassified and
made public
there has been so much discussion about
the concerns of over whether putin would
use chemical weapons uh nuclear weapons
biological weapons
does this increase
the administration's concern that putin
might lash out
in that way well as i say i'm not going
to characterize what uh vladimir putin
is thinking what the kremlin is thinking
or how this might impact their calculus
that is not uh the intent of putting the
information forward what it does is
underscore that this has been a
strategic blunder uh for russia um but
i'm not going to i'm not going to
characterize uh how you know vladimir
putin might be thinking about this i
will say um uh that we are prepare for
any and all contingencies as you know
there's a lot of work going on uh to be
prepared uh for contingencies and we've
also been very clear uh that should
russia act in that way there will be
severe consequences on the call kate
the readout that the white house put out
says the leaders discussed how the
united states is working around the
clock to fulfill the main security
assistance requests by ukraine we don't
know what specifically president of
ukraine asked for of president biden but
publicly at least he has called for
those polish migs he's called for
anti-aircraft
are has the president changed his
decision in that space is he now
potentially more open to providing the
publishers given that statement
we have propriet excuse me we have
provided an unprecedented amount of
security assistance to ukraine including
uh anti-air anti-tank
systems small munitions things that our
military have have assessed are the most
impactful weapons uh on the battlefield
in ukraine so as the president is making
a decision about what to send he takes
into account two things first the
assessment of our military about what is
most impactful what is best able to help
the ukrainian armed forces turn back
russian aggression and we've seen that
the weapons that we have provided have
been instrumental in helping them and
then secondly and then secondly as he
has said many many times he is not
looking for
direct american military conflict with
the russian military he's been clear
that uh providing uh the planes makes
this uh there are logistical
complications to providing the planes
and he's not going to make decisions
that is going to lead to direct conflict
between the united states military and
the russian military
has been clear including when he
addressed nato he doesn't think it's
enough he doesn't think that nato is
doing enough he thinks that their yes
has been a lot of assistance but it
doesn't go far enough for him to achieve
the goals
again the scope the scope and scale of
the assistance the security assistance
that we've provided to the ukrainians is
unprecedented we have uh worked very
very closely with them again as they
discussed on the call today we've worked
very closely with them to provide them
uh with the weapons that they need and
again the president takes into account
those two factors that i was just
talking about when making decisions but
that being said he we have sent two
billion dollars uh in security
assistance to ukraine and we continue to
supply them those um
uh those deliveries are happening daily
every day they're uh those weapons are
being delivered uh so we are doing
everything um
the president is making every effort to
ensure that they are getting what they
need very quickly any reaction to former
president trump
calling on
to release information about hunter are
you concerned about
so what i would say about that is
what kind of american let alone an
ex-president thinks that this
is the right time to enter into a scheme
with vladimir putin and brag about his
connections to vladimir putin there is
only one and it's donald trump
uh thank you kate earlier today germany
said it is willing to act as a security
guarantor for ukraine as part of the
peace negotiations between ukraine and
russia is the u.s willing to become a
guarantor of ukraine's security or
considering that option
so we are in constant discussion with
ukrainians about ways that we can help
ensure that they are sovereign and
secure but there's nothing specific
about security guarantee that i can
speak to at this time do you have any
more information on the 500 million in
budgetary aid uh for ukraine that was
mentioned as part of the readout between
the president's call with president
valencia did presidents lets you
specifically ask for this to help pay
for salaries and other government
functions and is it coming out of the
13.6 billion dollars in ukraine related
funding in the omnibus or is it separate
from that so it is financial assistance
the ukrainian government can use to
bolster its economy and pay for
budgetary expenses such as paying
salaries and maintaining government
services
we don't yet have additional detail on
where the money's coming from that is
being worked through but it is a
commitment that the president made today
what is the administration's current
view of whether the u.s embassy in
moscow should remain open
and how is the administration going
about evaluating whether or not to keep
the embassy so i don't have any
additional news to make on that at this
moment obviously we will come back to
you if there's development on that front
but there's nothing new that i can
announce from this podium at this moment
thank you thank you
on the economy
the yield curve for the 10-year treasury
note has inverted uh historically this
is viewed as a sign that
investors are pessimistic about the
long-term view the economy and the
expected recession is nearing so
can you tell us what the white house
believes is the prospects for recession
hearing and how concerned you might be
about
sure
so you know as chairman powell said
after the last fed meeting all signs are
that this is a strong economy and the
probability of a recession within the
next year is not particularly elevated
our team looks at a broad range of
indicators to understand the health of
the economy now and going forward uh
this is one but there are many many
others
and the other important indicators to to
include as we are assessing where the
economy stands
are things that frankly because of the
president's economic plan
you know we're able to confront from a
position of strength so that's for
example
the fastest economic growth in nearly 40
years a record 7.4 million jobs created
the fastest decrease in unemployment on
record to 3.8 percent and the first
major economy to return to pre-pandemic
levels so while historically this has
been one indicator it is far from the
only one and many of the other
fundamentals that we look at to assess
where we are economically are incredibly
strong and getting stronger and then on
the meeting later today between
president biden and moderate and
progressive house democrats
what should we
see as a sign of this meeting or we
should we expect that there's going to
be some kind of consensus around a plan
on the domestic side that is going to be
ready to ship over to the senate or
can you tell us more about what they're
going to discuss in the executive action
sure so this is part of his continued
engagement with the hill he's been
meeting with a number of different
caucuses over the course of the last
month he and this and our senior team
here at the white house uh we are
obviously uh constantly in close contact
uh with the hill i would not uh
i would not view this as a
decision-making meeting this is a
discussion of our shared priorities i
would not anticipate a deliverable
coming out of it this is again a
continued discussion of our strategic
priorities as we try to move forward on
our agenda just really quickly on india
that delete saying is there for the next
couple of days meeting with officials uh
is the u.s frustrated with india's
response uh to the to russia's
invasion of ukraine and uh what kind of
message is still even this team gonna be
delivering to the indian government on
that front sure
so as you note
the leap will be
will be in new delhi to continue our
ongoing consultations with the
government of india and advance a range
of issues in the u.s india economic
relationship and strategic partnership
he will meet with the government of
india to deepen cooperation to promote
inclusive economic growth and prosperity
and a free and open indo-pacific he will
consult closely with counterparts on the
consequences of russia's unjustified war
against ukraine and mitigating its
impact on the global economy he will
also discuss the priorities of the biden
administration including the promotion
of high quality infrastructure through
build back better world and the
development of an indo-pacific economic
framework
okay
i know this was asked yesterday but in
the last 24 hours says this white house
learned anything about why there is that
gap and call logs on january 6 from the
trump white house that was given over to
the select committee we have not my
answer has not changed from 24 hours ago
which is that i would refer you to uh to
the archives on that uh but certainly
where we can cooperate where we are
needed to cooperate uh to fill in that
gap we will but i would i would refer
you to the archives on that okay and
then um regarding the 500 million
dollars to ukraine um what is the
current explanation of why the president
has him sent over a nominee to the
senate to be the u.s ambassador to
ukraine right now what's the print
thinking on that
uh that's an excellent question and i'll
have to circle back with you on
hey on the on the pandemic the president
got his second booster shot today but
more than half of american adult
americans have not gotten their first
booster shot even as public health uh
you know officials warn about a fall
increase of ba2 variant um i wonder is
the white house concerned about that
like what what is the white house doing
to sort of help close that gap what's
the message to americans well our
message to americans first and foremost
is uh to get vaccinated and get boosted
it is the best way to protect yourself
from the virus and to protect against
the spread of the virus um what i would
say about uh what i would say about
um is that uh you know it is certainly
more transmissible than the original
omicron strain but there's no evidence
that it's more severe than omicron our
vaccines continue to work well against
ba2 uh particularly again with uh the
high level of protection provided by
boosters um so we continue to both
encourage people to get boosted but um i
would also point to all the work that
we've done to make boosters available to
make vaccines available there are 90 000
free locations nationwide where you can
get where you can get vaccinated and
boosted
and then lastly i would i would revisit
something we were talking about earlier
which is that we need congress to pass
the 22.5 billion in emergency coveted
funding immediately so that we can
maintain our tools to protect people and
to be uh fully prepared for the
possibility of any new variants yeah one
more on that last part
has the president or the white house
reached out specifically to any of these
legislators who have lobbed criticism
that you know you haven't used the money
that's already been allocated for
pandemic the fight against the pandemic
i don't have any specific engagements to
read out obviously we continue to work
closely with the hill the president has
stated very clearly that there's an
urgent need for this money uh and wants
to see it wants to see it done
how after printing trillions of dollars
taxpayers might want to know is there
not enough money to continue fighting
the pandemic trillions of dollars we
have
you're out of it is it all the
accounting done every single dollar so
we have the resources that we need in
this current moment what we need is this
funding to be able to plan for the
future to prepare for uh for as i say
the possibility of a new variant the
possibility of a new way we don't want
to be caught flat-footed we currently
have for example all of the vaccine
supply that we need to vaccinate and
boost every american but what we need to
have this money for is to prepare to be
ready
for the future as we as we know the
you know the virus can be unpredictable
and we need to be prepared and there's
an urgent need to do that
taxpayers will be skeptical i mean
trillions of dollars and obviously
billions more i think taxpayers want to
be prepared for the virus and they want
to make sure that we have the resources
that we need to keep them safe and
that's what this administration is
focused on
high protection sorry terry check yep
has called um the president has called
putin a war criminal he said that he
believes he will meet the legal
definition of a war criminal and the u.s
has vowed to pursue all accountability
measures including prosecution
sentencing for war crimes is long-term
imprisonment so how does all of that not
equate to calling for regime change
the president has been incredibly clear
about this he is not advocating for a
policy of regime change uh he what he
said a couple of days ago was a
statement of personal moral outrage uh
but we do not have a formal policy of
regime change what we are doing uh is
continuing to impose unprecedented costs
on russia we are ensuring that uh that
the russian uh that russia is paying for
this choice uh you know putin himself
has said that uh the costs the impact of
the sanctions has been uh has been
significant um so we are continuing to
to focus on our strategy of making sure
that we are providing security
assistance to ukraine
and imposing significant costs on russia
uh for these choices when he said that
he believes putin will meet the legal
definition of war criminal
was he not saying that he believes he
will be convicted of that crime
he was not in fact um and then does the
president and the national security team
here believe that ukraine can win and
push russia out of its borders and if so
has the u.s adjusted its strategy at all
in helping ukraine since they started to
win
well i would argue that from the outset
that we've done uh everything in our
power a tremendous tremendous amount uh
to provide ukraine with what it needs to
provide it with the resources to turn
back russian aggression that has been
the focus of our strategy again a
two-pronged strategy to impose costs and
provide uh the both the um
uh the security assistance and the
humanitarian assistance to support
ukraine is there any any reason why no
one from this administration has just
plainly said we think ukraine can win
this war
we i think in our actions and in the
support that we provided we've been very
clear uh that we're doing everything we
can to stand with ukraine and ensure
that they uh are able to push back uh
against russian aggression
on the southern border has dhs requested
national guard troops to be sent to the
border is that something the
administration is considering
uh as far as i know that is not
currently under consideration but i'm
happy to check in on it and come back to
you
thanks um
first uh
senator susan collins came out and in
support of judge jackson's confirmation
to the supreme court today uh do you
have a reaction to uh the kind of
confirmation that you'll have a
bipartisan vote there and then also you
know in her statement uh she said that
the process um is broken and uh it
should go back to kind of being based on
qualifications experience and not
ideology i'm curious what you think of
that the president is incredibly
grateful uh to senator collins for her
thorough and fair consideration and her
support the two of them spoke earlier in
this process and he appreciated her
thoughts and her insights
obviously her support speaks to the
qualification of judge jackson to sit on
the supreme court she
judge jackson has been working hard to
earn support and you know as you well
know responded to republicans requests
for in-person meetings by promising to
sit down with any senator who wanted and
she has engaged very directly she
answered over 20 hours of questions um
and you know she has earned the support
of
some of the most respected retired
conservative judges in the country and
the fraternal order of police and so
many others in law enforcement
so
she
is an incredibly qualified
nominee for the supreme court and the
president is very grateful for senator
collins
measured reasonable thorough and fair
consideration and ultimately support for
her what did he make of the other part
of the statement or the white house make
up the other part of the statement that
that the process as a whole is is broken
well i think what we're seeing uh in
immediate in the in the immediate case
uh is that the process is moving forward
she's receiving uh fair consideration uh
i think she was the president was
incredibly proud
of the way she handled herself during
the hearings and thought she very
effectively spoke to her judicial
philosophy
and handled incoming criticism so i
won't speak to the whether the process
writ large is broken as we are focused
uh narrowly in this moment on the
process in front of us and i would say
the process in front of us is working
and i think uh again you know senator
collins uh support today um the
president was very grateful for it
um back to the intel release i'm
wondering if this is partially just an
effort to
embarrass vladimir putin to sort of
publicly
shame him or or something it
it it comes across as
you know you you say that you can't
speak for the kremlin but then you're
saying he feels misled by his advisors
it seems like
there might be something going on here
no no our aim again our aim is to show
that uh this has been a strategic
blunder for russia uh that there is um
ultimately this is going to leave them
weaker it is not going to leave them
stronger and i think uh making this
information public simply contributes to
uh to the picture that uh that
strategically um uh they are having to
uh to reorganize to refit uh and and
that shows that um again this was uh a
terrible decision for them and at the
end of the day as we've long said as
we've said from the outset uh as we said
even uh before they invaded uh we said
that this would be a strategic mistake
for them and i think that that is borne
out going back to the covid funding i
think it was your answer to ed
um i'm trying to read between the lines
just a little bit but you had said
previously we asked for 22 billion
dollars as emergency funding that
wouldn't need any offsets
now we would like congress to get us
this money um are you saying that you're
willing to accept offsets uh that and
also
are you willing to accept less than 22
billion well what i would say is we have
been very clear that we need this money
now and we're hopeful that congress is
nearing a solution um and you know again
the president called for this initial
22.5 billion uh as emergency funding
but at the end of the day we need the
money it's important it's critical for
our preparedness for the next uh in the
next phase of of coven and being
prepared so we're not caught flat-footed
so
ultimately uh we are uh uh we are
hopeful that congress is nearing a
solution on this and we should take that
as you're willing to accept the offsets
you should no you should take it as what
i said which is that we're hopeful that
congress is reaching a solution on this
and congress will determine uh
ultimately where we net out on this
thank you very much kate um going back
to her question who the white house
believe is winning this war
i think that uh the white house believes
that uh ukraine has been uh has fought
valiantly has uh has been
incredibly uh brave and
uh resolved in the face of of um a tr of
atrocious brutal uh invasion from russia
i think what you've seen in the actions
from this white house
is that we have provided weapons we have
provided assistance we have been there
every step of the way and will continue
to be
and we have put enormous enormous
economic pressure uh on russia in order
to uh in order to hopefully uh drive
this conflict uh to to a solution so um
you know i think again i don't know that
i have to say it i think that our
actions show uh and the support that we
provided shows that uh that we believe
that ukraine has been uh incredibly um
incredibly brave incredibly strong and
we're going to continue to support them
as they move forward
yeah do you mind because president
zelansky tweeted uh also that president
biden talked about uh a new package of
sanctions could you have anything more
specific on it so i don't have anything
that i can preview in this moment but
certainly we are continuing to look at
options to uh to expand and deepen our
sanctions and i anticipate that we would
probably have more for you on that in
the coming days okay thank you ken uh
two quick ones hopefully um could you
give us any steer on the additional
capabilities bit of that readout in from
the zalinski call
is there is there a shift in thinking
perhaps ukraine needs
a different category of weapons not just
enough to
hold the russians back but actually to
push them
push them back
so
so an example of uh one of the one of
those additional capabilities something
that we talked about a little bit last
week while we were in europe uh you know
uh
short ship to shore uh capability
anti-ship capability that's just one
example um you know beyond that i'm not
going to go into further detail on
what's being discussed except to say
that we're doing everything we can to
ensure
that ukraine has what it needs on the
battlefield the other one is uh today
boris johnson said
very black and white he said sanctions
western sanctions not just british or g7
sanctions should stay in place until the
russian troops are all gone
that was a lot more
black and white than anything that's
come out of the white house um did you
does the white house share that kind of
uh
maximalist goal with sanctions are they
gonna stay there until the last russian
trips are gone that's not something that
i'm going to uh to be able to pre-state
in this moment uh i will let uh i'll let
boris johnson and the uk government
speak for themselves
uh yes yeah thanks kate um there have
been some reports recently that some
democratic senators on the hill have
expressed concerns um about eric
garcetti's nomination um to be an
ambassador to india um does the white
house still have confidence in him and
uh its ability to get confirmed
uh we do uh we do have the president has
confidence in mayor garcetti believes he
will be an excellent representative in
india uh i would remind you that his
nomination advanced unanimously with
bipartisan support in committee and
we're continuing to engage with senators
and working to earn bipartisan support
for his nomination uh and believe he
should receive a vote in the senate
expeditiously yeah and um earlier this
month uh president zolensky signed a
decree to combine ukraine's national tv
channels into one platform
saying he wants to create a unified
information policy um ukraine also
announced that it was banning 11
political parties with ties to russia um
is the white house concerned at all
about these moves um by the ukrainians
so this is the first that i'm hearing of
it i will look into it i'm happy to talk
to our national security team and get
back to you thanks
okay
high praise
you had mentioned that the
administration encourages boosters you
talked about the work you've done on
that but given that covid cases are down
and that the pace of boosters has been
sluggish will there be an actual public
campaign by the president or the
administration more of an outward effort
to get people to get their boosters well
i think we'll we will continue to do the
work we've been doing and today we
launched a new website covet.gov which
gives people uh what they need to
track transmission in their community to
find a test to treat location so an
opportunity a location where you can go
you can get a test and if you're
positive you can get an antiviral
so this website is part of our effort
our continued and ongoing effort to make
sure that people have what they need to
deal with covet as we move into uh
potentially the next phase of this uh of
this disease um
you know from the outset we have said
and continue to believe because the
science shows that getting vaccinated
getting boosted
is the best thing that you can do in
order to protect yourself from the virus
so that has been a big piece of our uh
public messaging that's been a big piece
of our message to the country and it
will continue to be
today describe this new moment where he
said kobet no longer controls our lives
how critical is it that americans get
boosted to stay in this new moment right
now it's it's important and our message
has consistently been that it is
important to uh is important to get
boosted the science shows it is the best
way to to prevent the spread of the
virus and to um
and to protect you and your loved ones
and your family and your friends from
getting sick so
our message will always be it is
important to go out and get boosted we
have we are doing everything in our
power we have done everything in our
power to make sure that boosters are
free and available to everybody in the
country
thank you um regarding the president's
budget proposal which was released
earlier this week uh senator manchin is
already saying that he can't support
this so-called billionaire's tax because
it would tax unrealized gains on certain
assets i wanted to hear your response to
that and i'm also wondering if he sticks
with that you know given his opposition
does that mean this this proposal is doa
well what i would say is that the uh the
president's budget is a classic joe
biden budget it is focused on uh
security it is focused on our on
security in our communities security
abroad
and it was designed in order to help
ensure that we have the money in reserve
to pay for and bring down the deficit uh
even after congress sends us whatever
they ultimately uh send us on the
proposals that he very much wants to see
passed to lower prescription drug costs
to lower the cost of child care to
tackle the climate crisis so
the key priorities in this budget
are those and
and ensuring that the wealthiest pay
their fair share obviously
i think senator manchin and president
biden share a belief that the rich
should pay their fair share
and we'll allow the process of
negotiation to work itself out we're not
i'm obviously not going to negotiate
from the podium
but i do think that senator manchin and
president biden share that fundamental
belief that the rich should should pay
their fair share the wealthiest i should
say should pay their fair share um and
so we'll continue to work with him and
to work with congress to move these
forward
21 states have filed a lawsuit against
the government because of the mass
mandates and transportation i wonder if
the white house is prepared through the
cnc to issue some new guidance to leak
his mass mandates
uh so i don't have any news to make on
this at this moment i will say um
these are conversations that are
underway and certainly when we have news
to make on this we'll come back to you
thank you kate um when i asked
sullivan uh the question of whether no
one in the administration had said
definitively whether or not the white
house thinks that ukraine can win this
war um he referred me to the pentagon
and moments ago when the same question
was asked to you you said um no i don't
know i have what i don't know i have to
say it um
the president has said i don't care what
putin thinks so why isn't the
administration being more definitive on
this question is it for fear that this
might provoke moscow is it that you
don't have a clear definition of what
victory might look like over there i
think what is important here as i said
in my previous answer i think what's
important here is our actions i think we
have uh we have provided the security
assistance we've provided the weapons uh
to ukraine we continue to support
ukraine we continue to do everything in
our power to ensure that they have what
they need so i think if there's uh i
don't think there should be any question
about whether uh this white house and
this president uh is doing everything in
his power to uh to support ukraine in
the face of russian
uh two aggression one on your own one
electric vehicle so on you're wrong
today uh secretary uh lincoln announced
new ascension against iran over the
ballistic missile
activities will this endanger the
nuclear type
sorry
the second part of the second part is in
danger of the nuclear nuclear talk
uh uh no not at all uh in fact uh these
sanctions are not connected to the iran
deal they demonstrate in fact what we
have always said which is that we will
continue to hold iran accountable for
its missile proliferation and support to
proxy networks as we work diplomatically
to place strict limits on its nuclear
program so that will be true whether we
are back in the nuclear deal or not and
the sanctions that we're applying today
will remain in place whether or not
we're back in the nuclear deal but
as you know it is our firm view that
getting out of the deal was a disaster
and second that these other problems
missiles and proxies are better
addressed without iran at the nuclear
breakout threshold
so ultimately we are able to hold iran
accountable on issues like the missile
program
while
continuing to work toward a potential
deal to limit their nuclear program
second question on the electric vehicle
so yesterday you announced investment in
electric vehicle
and this week actually a chinese company
called simcore which is shanghai
energy new material technology just
announced a new electric vehicle battery
investment in ohio which will create
around
1200 jobs we know pushing cutting edge
technology
and preserving supply chain is by the
administration's
priority but would you also worry about
national security aspect and future
supply chain concern over a chinese
investment on those items
well as you say a a significant economic
priority a significant plank of the
biden economic agenda uh is bringing our
supply chains to america making more in
america manufacturing in america
the president has been very focused on
taking steps to ensure that we're doing
that and we're seeing investment um you
know you'll all remember the investment
at intel announced a couple of months
ago uh you know these are investments
that uh are in happening in part because
president biden is creating an
environment where
companies feel like they will get the
support and they will therefore bring
their jobs here on the national security
question i would only say of course we
would always
review and undertake all of the
necessary steps but i don't have
anything beyond that to say
oh okay thank you all appreciate it
you